from the post millennial Yingling
sponsors PA Pride drag show for families
quote need your drag fix before our
iconic Music Fest drag show well the
Queens return to Music Fest Cafe Press
by Yingling on June 30th so here's what
I want to clarify they deleted this
tweet that's that's very interesting the
venue's title
the venue is called Music Fest Cafe
presented by Yingling that's the name of
the venue so if you were to host a
birthday party there you'd say hey show
up to Music Fest Cafe presented by
Yingling that's where the party is
however a lot of people are trying to
use it as an absolute defensive Yingling
I don't think it's an absolute defense
but I think it is a decent one
they say the festival's Facebook page
wrote on June 12th uh this this post was
well on Twitter they deleted it on
Twitter we uh timcast news team reached
out they confirmed it is an all ages
drag show you can bring your kids and
they confirmed that it is still going on
and they don't know why the post was
removed that being said I'm gonna say it
I would I would I'm not gonna be like oh
Yingling you know you got a boycott that
whatever I'm gonna be like you guys need
a statement on this one Yingling needs
to say if that is the case but look we
sponsored a venue and then the venue
does what they do we didn't know they
were doing this we're not okay with that
and I think that's satisfactory as far
as I'm concerned but considering what's
been going on considering the Bud Light
effect in the backlash I think people
are probably already boycotting Yingling
over this I well I think it's possible
that Yingling might even be too afraid
to release a statement because they
might be thinking not enough people know
about this yet and if we release a
statement more of them will and it will
upset them and we don't want the Bud
Light effect to occur here well at least
about 45 000 right now know about it
yeah I mean look if they released a
statement saying we are sorry we
sponsored this you know if they J in
being honest like if they genuinely
didn't know what was happening then
please say that I'll go out you know
I'll buy a uh I I can't say I'll become
a customer for the first time because I
already drink Yingling but if they were
intentionally sponsoring this and
they're going to continue to sponsor the
stuff then no I will not buy English if
Yingling puts out a statement and says
not only did we not sponsor this event
but we are condemning it oh you stand
against it I will go to the local liquor
store and buy all of the Yingling they
have right now give me an excuse to buy
more Yingling that's what I'm asking you
for but here's the crazy thing the venue
deleted the tweet I wonder because so my
understanding is that the uh the the
former head of Yingling
very pro-trump and I think the family is
conservative pro-trump I think maybe the
Tweet came down because they got wind of
it because people were tagging them in
it being like what's this all about they
probably said hey take us off that we
didn't sponsor this event and so the
Tweet got removed apparently people are
saying they edited the Facebook post to
remove sponsored by Yingling or whatever
but the event's still happening and the
venue is still a Yingling sponsored
venue so I still think it'd be
appropriate for them to issue a
statement but the point I was going to
make it's been a very bad pride month
for the pride people very good pride
month for me yeah I mean uh someone
mentioned super chats that Xbox did
bring back their pride logo but either
way the fact that there's been pushback
at all the fact that worker the workers
at Starbucks says they were told to take
down decorations the fact that Target
said hide it in the back right this
stuff's being pushed back very very
heavily yeah it's been it's been a bad
month I think it's pretty incredible and
I think it tells American consumers the
power that they actually do have I think
so after and we hear like uh it's
happening anyways or you don't want to
like draw attention to yourself or you
know just let them have the month or
whatever and this is the first time
you're seeing the tides turn with
substantial evidence that if you are uh
irritated enough you can in fact enact
change well you know what I think these
people didn't understand conservatives
have always been against this but mostly
didn't care moderate liberal types
mostly just don't care and they were
like yeah you know live in the live then
they started going after kids bringing
in these books that were gratuitous
targeting children doing these weird
things and then they lost the moderates
the moderates now into the conservance
said please help me get this smut out of
my my child's school and now the
conservatives are like yeah we're gonna
get rid of all of it yeah so now it's
all getting pushed out Target still
sells the uh loves win love wins
doormats and stuff like that and you
want to say like actually that is a very
long time ago we are well past that
being the issue the core issue for this
group and I think that's the problem I
think now that they've moved on to
pushing a gen underless Society full of
people who are torturing themselves
physically you know people don't want to
do that which is so funny because the
whole purpose of of being gay is your
gender but then where the but then there
are multiple genders it's like so then
which one is it right yeah like are you
bisexual if there's more there's only
two whatever Johns Hopkins for a second
but it took it back said lesbians are
not not man yes oh you're a non-man at
the table the interesting thing about
that so this is like this week probably
everyone knows this but Johns Hopkins
had the definition for a second they say
they they disavow it now but uh lesbian
is a non-man other non-men yes but Johns
Hopkins was the first the Johns Hopkins
I'm sorry it said a non-man attracted to
a non-man and so my explanation was that
means that magnets are lesbians that's
true
if they're both negative yeah right
opposite attract negative and positive
North and South oh okay yeah so that
means I got one for you
all matter except for that which
comprises a man is a lesbian you know
why because that's true gravity yeah
because Mass attracts yeah the other
thing is that they left the term man in
the definition of gay so right it's just
lesbian that gets to be not gendered but
I was going to point out that Johns
Hopkins was the first uh Medical Center
in the U.S in 1966 to offer a change of
sex surgery like it is indicative of of
the direction they're drifting the only
reason that they stopped being at the
Forefront of gender ideology and gender
inter medical intervention was because
their chief of a psychology uh Paul
McHugh I think I'm getting his name
right uh was like no if people have a
gender issue we should help them but we
should only treat them for psychological
issues we should not offer them
physiological medical intervention and
that stopped it for 30 years he's the
one who campaigned to make sure these
surgeries weren't covered under Medicaid
and then eventually John talking
University was like no we really want to
make the money but that's my editorial
there but we are actually going to
racist and now they have one of the
leading uh gender I don't even know what
about gender centers in the U.S like
this was something that has been
happening for a long time and I think
the fact this this school put out a
definition got hit with backlash said oh
no we didn't mean that we're just trying
to be respectful of all genders like
they are telling you the direction
they're going in they have been doing
this for decades and yet people
say like oh will they fixed it so we'll
just let it go they they said they
didn't mean to erase all the lesbians so
you know it's fine a racist women in
general just all women and this is
something I mean I wrote about this
during uh women's History Month Phyllis
Schlafly was warning against this when
everyone was campaigning for uh the
Equal Rights Amendment he said she said
repeatedly that it wasn't about giving
men and women equality it's about
erasing the differences between men and
women always I just want everyone to
hear that over and over again like it's
not about helping women it's about
deleting the differences between genders
which is inherently destructive to
society to the family right that's the
whole point they don't want men and
women they want men and women to not
know how to relate to one another so
that we'll have weak families because if
you have a weak family of a weak society
and then there's less of a competing
Authority structure for the state or
whatever perverse ideological worldview
they want to try to build Out From the
Ashes I don't want to live in a
genderless world and I'm very
comfortable with that I feel like
everyone should be against that I got
good news for you you never will they'll
try to push this stuff but ultimately
men or men and women are women even if
they don't live up to it well I mean
depending on what happens with the the
chemicals in our Foods birth control and
things like this seeping into our water
and maybe yeah well it's only the 15th
right is it June 15th 2018 today we
still have half the month to go let's
see what happens it's a wild ride no no
no no group has done more harm to gay
people than gay activists and you can
change that for lesbian trans
um you know I've been on the show a
bunch the audience knows I'm married to
a dude I don't really care about it no
one cares
um but we were talking the other night
like we were out in the field doing
something in the farm and Andrew my
better half who doesn't talk he's he's
pretty quiet uh farmer and he was like
remember 10 years ago when like no one
cared and he's like isn't it miserable
he was like I never he's like and we're
in our you know 40s he's like I've never
been more embarrassed to be gay than I
am right now wow and we live on a farm
in the middle of nowhere he's like it's
just miserable I'm like no I get you is
like it is miserable he's like it's just
miserable I mean so no one has hurt gay
people more than gay activists and I
would put the trans movement as the head
of that but like honestly 10 years ago
it was so much easier like people would
be like oh it's pride month and like
yeah for a second like yeah I don't care
like just just leave me alone but it but
but I don't think it's gay activist I
think it's leftists no well yeah but
leftists but in general well these are
white liberal women that's true they've
used us the way they've used BLM the
black people to push BLM the way they've
used Greta thundberg to push green
issues right it's just it's just
miserable like the best thing you could
do to celebrate pride month is just just
shut up
leave it alone and I do agree with you
when they started bringing in the kids
it's when people like Andrew and I were
like we want nothing to do with this
yeah oh my God this is so freaking weird
and disgusting and perverted and now the
argument is becoming uh because we've
talked about it we've had we've had
people ask us do you think gay marriage
was the slippery slope to what they're
doing
but I I disagree I'm like when when we
say like look like as you mentioned you
and your husband are off doing your own
thing and you're on a farm in the middle
of nowhere like I don't care about that
like you should have the the rights and
access and I've I've I've had that
position my whole life when it came to
the gay marriage question just because
something happens
and then another thing happens doesn't
mean that one is the fault of the other
right if we because that argument is
what they use to try and ban guns they
say oh when when more people have guns
you see more gun death and it's like
well okay sure but doesn't mean you
don't have the rights I'm not going to
take away someone's right to keep in
bear arms because some people do bad
things we ban those bad things get rid
of it we protect the good things I don't
know that it's it's gay marriage itself
I think it's the the uh corporate the
money around lobbying for gay marriage
like once that victory was achieved we
had to then take all of this momentum
that we had and turned it into something
else that we could sell and make money
off of and that benefited the medical
industry that pushes trans ideology it
benefits corporations like Target that
can sell you a rainbow t-shirt and say
like look I support you and dragged you
back in I don't know that it's like the
legal issue but I do think it's that uh
all of the momentum that it had had to
go somewhere and someone was like I have
decided I'm going to steer the ship in
this crazy Direction and they will
follow I think if you're a communist
you're never satiated and so they won
quote unquote Victory I'm sure you think
a victory they won the victory of gay
marriage but like that that wasn't it it
was like what's next and and it's the
same with like the green movement they
never were like well we got that so now
we're done it's like nope the same with
the guns right we got our loopholes not
enough what's the next one what's the
next I think the left is never satiated
with what they don't ever have one
Victory one Victory just leads to a
greater one and I agree with you I think
like marriage like should people
whatever you can argue we can all
disagree and that's wonderful but no one
was like all right we're all done
everyone should close up shop thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time